if you want to have success as an
entrepreneur go work for somebody who's
already had huge success in your
industry work for somebody who you want
to model make all your mistakes while
getting paid and then go launch your
business it'll dramatically decrease
your chances of failure hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and today
maintain a question from a YouTube
viewer Queen Zuba great name Thank You
YouTube viewers wrote in saying thank
you for making this great video I've
been thinking a survey on magazines from
four years ago I'm actually working a
magazine now for almost six months my
question is when you think I'm ready to
start on my own I've gained many great
contacts in the market great experience
but the magazine i'm at is not really
successful they've been struggling for
the past four years because of bad
management and planning any advice hey
Queen Zuba this is great i love it if
you want to have success in an industry
go work for somebody who has had success
who is doing it and you can learn from
them now were you're right right now you
have two options okay this is important
the first I'd be looking at can I get a
job at a more successful magazine okay I
don't want to model the strategies of
people who aren't making it there's
something there because they've hired
some staff you don't know how much
success they've had in the past maybe
was cyclical but still they're not how
excessive right now you want to model
yourself and learn from people who have
had a lot of success so now that you
have some experience in the industry I
would be looking like going to work for
a different company a different magazine
someone who is doing well someone who
has good management and has good systems
and procedures and is making money and
is growing those are the guys you want
to learn from so go look for those
opportunities the second thing when are
you ready to start on your own start
part-time start don't just jump into it
full time and quit your job if you feel
you have experienced you feel you have
the contacts maybe you don't know
everything yet but start on the side
start something small starts helping
part-time start working towards your
vision now it's never too soon as long
as you are at survival as long as you're
making enough money from your job to
support yourself and pay
your bills and you're learning from them
then start on the side get going as you
start it up you'll get new ideas you'll
build momentum you start seeing things
happen you'll start getting some
traction and when your new business has
made enough that you can survive from it
then you're ready to jump ship then
you're ready to leave your job and go
work on your business full time you have
done all the right things
congratulations most people don't take
your path and most people fail with
their companies so I'm proud of you good
job well done but you still have
important work ahead of you so to recap
go find a company who is successful for
anybody who's starting the business it's
great to be in the industry but you want
to model yourself after the guys who are
killing it the guys are doing well not
the guys who are sucking and can't pay
their employees in and have bad
management okay you can learn from their
failures and say I don't want to be like
this but it doesn't tell you what you
should be like so go find that company
work for them and then start your
business on the side start part-time
start evening start weekend's build some
traction build some momentum until you
can get to the point we are making money
and making enough money to be quit your
job and focus on that full time good
luck Queens uba love the name everybody
watching you like the video please give
it a thumbs up below and I want to hear
from you if you have a comment about
this video please leave it below makes
you want to do more for you I love
seeing the comments come in and if you
have a question for your own business
I'd love to try to answer for you in the
comments section as well I always read
those I read every comment personally
and I really love seeing them so thank
you guys I'll see you soon
you